do you kind of watch who you collaborate
with if they don't kind of align with
like where you are well yeah i think
like as just a as a man with principles
like
i want to create the way i want to
create art is i have some brand filters
for myself i always want to make things
that i think are
incredibly dope artistically excellent
but i also want things that are
wholesome
you know what i'm saying so
like you don't cuss in your music right
no i don't
um
i saw music as like a dividing something
that like divided me and my my family
and
at a certain point time you know i get
in the car my cannabis cd'd be broken in
half for a while you know what i'm
saying so my mom just was like nah you
can't play she just didn't you know when
you're 14.
she didn't appreciate getting [ __ ]
yeah she didn't she did
um
but now it's a brain song by the way it
is
it's it's not pc anymore right and word
nomentry
yes
second round ko
um
so yeah but now it's cool to see the
music that i make is able to bring
people together i see like at a show
a guy will be there and he'll bring his
son he's like this is my 12 year old son
it's his first concert ever and we get
to come do this together you know that's
fine oh that's crazy so yeah when i go
to do collaborations like i've done
you know
i've had collaborations with people from
all different walks of life and world
views um but we just try to make sure
that when we create something we create
something that your family we align with
yeah i'm saying like there's middle
ground there's there's stuff we can
create so
fonte just jumped on the record and we
did something that was great